[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute cookie
du also essbaren keks teig ohne rohe
eier und ihr könnt aus meinem basic
rezept heute 1000 varianten machen ich
glaube ich zeitweise drei varianten
vielleicht doch mehr mal schauen
cookie dough ist ja eigentlich so ein
trend aus amerika meinen augen ist es
gar kein trend mehr sondern ein
grundnahrungsmittel also im fang jetzt
direkt mal an wir können beim cookie
dough kein mehl einfach als solches
benutzen
es ist jetzt hier ganz normal das mehl
type 405 wir müssen das aber vorher
einmal erhitzen erwärme ich mache das im
backofen das dient einfach dazu dass man
so ein bisschen die bakterien abtötet
das ist strenggenommen naturprodukt und
dafür mache ich das jetzt so dass
nämlich ein backblech gibt einfach das
mehl darauf verteilen dass so ein
bisschen ihr könnt es übrigens auch in
der pfanne machen einfach in der
beschichtete pfanne nehmen und das
können sie überredet die promis okay
waren im urlaub kommt frisch aus dem
urlaub und danach war in der türkei für
und haselnuss creme
dazu gibt es auch beim extra video daher
haben sie das hinter der kamera auch
ziemlich braun und das gilt jetzt in den
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
erreichen 16 11 minuten
das meer nimmt auf jeden fall eine
andere farbe an nicht wundern dass geben
wir aber bis zum auskühlen an die seite
und jetzt machen wir weiter mit den
anderen zutaten ich habe jetzt hier
butter wichtig ist dass ihr die butter
erhitzt das habe ich jetzt in der
mikrowelle gemacht geringe wattzahl
sonst klappt die euch eine ganze
mikrowelle schmutzig und ganz ganz
wichtig ist dass er die butter bitte
auskühlen dass die gebe ich jetzt hier
meine schüssel und anschließend gibt ihr
zucker dazu und beim zucker ist es so
dass ich eine mischung aus weißem zucker
und braunem rohrzucker nehme
[Musik]
und dann gibt mir noch von meinem
vanille extrakt dazu das gibt dem ganzen
so eine gewisse grund note und dann
schmeckt euer cookie dough feiertag auch
nicht nur nach zu kapoor und ich finde
auch gerade das gemisch zwischen weißen
und braunen zucker das darfst wieder so
eine kamelie note in den nur pur weißen
zucker nehmen würde dann wäre so ein
bisschen punkig also ich finde das ist
einfach dieses feine was er dann am ende
raus schmecken werden und falls ihr euch
wundert das ist auch wichtig zu sagen
warum die butter abgekühlt sein soll ich
möchte nicht dass die zuckerkristalle
sich darin sofort auflösen und die
konsistenz verändert sich ansonsten also
die konsistenz so ist perfekt haben so
kannst du doch noch mal nah rangehen wie
ich habe ganz oft schon cookie dough
ausprobiert und die rezeptur gefällt mir
am besten so und jetzt kommt das
abgekühlte mail zum einen dass ich sieht
das ganze nochmal weil auch hier noch
ganz kleines stückchen drin sind und ich
möchte die eben nicht drin haben also
einmal noch mit dazu sieben und die ganz
klar und mengenangaben oh gott oh gott
gar nicht gesagt findet ihr unten in der
video beschreibung
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alles miteinander
verrührt und mit dem kochlöffel
funktioniert das einfach besser weil die
masse ist schon sehr
also nicht kompakt sondern klebrig
definitiv aber halt auch sehr wuchtig so
hamas ist auch mal so und da gebe ich
jetzt einen schluck milch rein sondern
ein bisschen und ihr werdet selber
merken wie die konsistenz ist wie sie
euch am besten gefällt ich werde das
ganze gleich auch noch mal für 15
minuten in den kühlschrank tun damit
auch noch mal alles richtig schön ziehen
kann
also nach 15 minuten im kühlschrank ist
die konsistenz schon echt anders daher
gibt die mich auf jeden fall dazu
auch ich hatte als ich das rezept hin
und her getestet habe denken wieso soll
ich jetzt noch nichts dazu tun oder
nicht aber milch in kombination mit dem
mehl ergibt dann schon wieder eine ganz
andere konsistenz aber es braucht halt
daneben kurze kühlschrank zeitzone teile
ich meinen tag auf und zwar in drei
portionen wenn ich möchte drei
verschiedene varianten machen
und grundsätzlich könnt ihr ja unendlich
viele variationen machen schreibt mir
dafür einfach mal in die kommentare was
für variationen ihr noch kennt was ihr
mögt vielleicht kann ich ja noch ein
zweites video machen mit zum beispiel
zehn weiteren verschiedenen cookie dough
varianten
ich bin übrigens die sicher ob es cookie
dough oder kido oder boogie darf also
groß
jetzt habe ich den ersten cookie dough
mit weißem schokoladenstückchen getoppt
den zweiten mit ganz schönen bunten
streuseln und den dritten mit loriots
und vollmilch chance und ich weiß gar
nicht welche ich das jetzt erst das
probieren sagt ich probiert einfach mal
meine persönlichen favoriten nämlich den
mit den vom nicht chance und das riecht
schon so gut dass rihs einfach so so gut
nein ehrlich wir haben gesagt gerade ein
ernstes jahr und jetzt ofen vorheizen
diesen ein sehr geil
dann soll man es schmeckt so als hätte
man jetzt einen teig vorbereitet der den
ofen wann dann muss das heißt es
schmeckt so ehrlich es schmeckt so
ehrlich gesagt ja und ich schon vorher
gesagt genau du einmal nach und am ende
die rest sind genauso schmeckt richtig
richtig gut natürlich nicht günstig
einfach nur ein traum macht es unbedingt
nach ihr werdet es nicht bereuen und
schreibt mir unbedingt in die kommentare
die weiteren möglichkeiten ich möchte
gern zweites video dazu machen und dann
einfach mal verschiedene crazy
möglichkeiten ausprobieren wie solltet
kümmel oder also ganz viel freude ihm
nachmachen vergesslich diesem video ein
bäumchen nach oben da zu lassen und
unbedingt ein kostenloses abo hier unten
und dann sehen wir uns wenn man nächsten
rezept video cherokee
[Musik]